you go to the Golden Globes I'm sure
you've been there before do you like
these award shows I just hope it goes
better than last year last year I was
like really nervous
mm-hmm it was my very first time at one
of those things and it's funny because
part of why I was reticent to take this
job is the only time I'd done on-camera
sexual nudity was with Don Cheadle on
this great funny show called House of
Lies on Showtime
but I I didn't know we were actually
gonna shoot the on-camera sex scene
that's not what the way I read the
script but it ended up that yes we did
shoot an on-camera sex scene it kind of
went awry I won't bore you with the
details but we ended up having to shoot
it three times and I had such an intense
reaction to the experience that I call
my manager afterwards I was like never
doing on-camera sexual nudity again like
I'm just not the person I just was too
upsetting it was a lot I mean it was
from behind though so it was like also
like very exposing me there's a camera
like right there so I'm walking down the
red car should I demonstrate now I want
you brought it up but I'm on the red
carpet and you know I see him talking to
Jeffrey to see he's all right sometimes
you see Don Cheadle yeah and I'm just
like in that what I might be in right
now which is that overstimulated mode
Reese say something really stupid and
you try to be funny and you're not and I
like walk up and I'm like hey Don do you
remember me you got the ass three times
this is your red parts is your red
carpet banter to the Don Cheadle and my
kids are standing right behind me and I
turn I look behind him and there's
literally not just his kids but his wife
[Music]
and I think like they don't know I'm an
actress they don't know what I'm
referring to
they they literally think like some
woman just came up to me on the red
carpet like you're over here so I I
start to cry
he's short of dry why are you crying
he was like the coolest guy he's a nice
guy
honestly Andy took really good care of
me on set to like if you're going to do
it yeah
[Applause]
[Music]